we understand you watch a lot of Razzie
nominated films what's the reason behind
that well so years ago I was writing and
writing and writing and writing and
writing and one of my really good
friends she's a playwright also in New
York she says do I see you writing all
the time she's like what would it be
read nothing
I don't read plays and she was like
you're not gonna be great until you
watch read the good stuff and the bad
stuff you have to watch it all and so
that didn't even make sense at the time
until I just decided to go into the
[Music]
playwriting bookstore in New York and I
just to pick up plays and it wouldn't
matter if I knew the playwright or not
and Vig you would start to see the
difference between our really
well-constructed play and one that it's
not as well constructed and so the
Razzies I like to make fun of films who
aren't the best that's out there and so
I watched the good stuff and I also make
sure that I watch the bad stuff to make
sure that I'm constructing narratives in
a more progressive in the worst way do
you ever watch the bad stuff and say
this isn't actually bad and sometimes
the good stuff this isn't I'm just like
not impressed the story not really
actually most of the time if it's Wylie
kind of seen as bad I kind of found it
to be bad and what I've recently started
to do was because the reality is even to
make a bad film takes an incredible
amount of work it really does and so I
don't necessarily go in now to judge
work but to rather glean whatever the
artist is trying to give me to see from
what they're trying to say whether
they're successful at it or not that's
not really for me to judge like I used
to judge in the past but rather to just
enjoy the experience for what it is but
I do find as you say sometimes the
movies that everybody's just saying just
so phenomenal and so good it just
doesn't resonate with
me as much because I think that in the
approach to try to appeal to everyone
you appeal to no one as opposed to
trying to appeal to someone and allowing
others to participate in that as well so
I think that's what kind of the
difference probably is and for your your
first film you cast actors that you knew
is that right yes so I knew Kim brown he
was somebody that I knew I didn't know
the ladies and I didn't know the other
guy that was paid in Houston I didn't
know them at the time but I knew them
they were kind of swirling around from
other people that I knew and I knew okay
I can only have four characters not only
for a couple people but a couple of
dollars a day and that's that's what we
did so we did a very small for a person
cast and they were pretty much in every
scene of the entire movie what locations
did you get like I got the locations
that I could get but it is funny because
when you don't have any money you can't
go right high end you know high-end bar
with full with patrons and a waitress
walks up and does this but then when
you're the reality of it you can't
afford that location so I think what I
would have done differently than what I
did now is I would allow each seemed to
kind of take place anywhere and being
whatever locations you find that made
sense in those regards
would make sense in those regards and
you do it like that so then you're just
going and looking for whatever locations
allow you in as opposed to trying to be
so specific and not being able to
accomplish it because I think even in my
first film like every restaurant every
hand nobody was there we couldn't afford
background you just couldn't afford it
so nobody was there and we tried to make
it like how nobody's doing because
[Laughter]
yeah but I would I would definitely
adjust how I would do it especially if
you don't have money you don't have
money you just provide the framework and
being you go let the universe kind of
tells you this is where you can feel
this is where you can feel and then put
it in those locations or a location that
you already know that you can get
forgive me how much did you spend on
your first film it's my first film I did
it for $45,000 yeah we did on 45,000
which made sense because Ava Duvernay
had just done a film I think it was I
will follow her she did it for 50,000
and so I'm thinking like oh we're right
in line with what they're doing at this
time and again it was a very insulated
isolated film that she was pretty much
at her aunt's house the entire film and
has Charlie Richardson Whitfield in it
but it was like a master it gonna able
to market and get her voice up here you
know we didn't have the same resources
and we were from Atlanta so nobody and
nobody really cared about our project
okay and it was a feature it was a
feature a little bit too long and I
remember also when we went into the
first cut I was bored out of my mind for
the first 26 minutes of the film so the
first 26 minutes of the film I totally
cut out of the project because again I
didn't know how to necessarily get into
story in that way and I didn't have a
mentor to kind of like guide me and so I
think that's another thing people cannot
be afraid to lose things in the process
cuz in losing those 26 minutes I think I
really gained a solid one hour and 30
minutes film but if I was trying to get
to this two hour time frame that I was
initially trying to do we would have
lost a lot of onions from the very
beginning and you cut that and when you
started editing it yes I remember my
first time watching it and I was just
like this is not interesting and even
now when I go back and I read that
screenplay I realized what I was doing I
was first 26 minutes and I wasn't
interested in and so now our Pro stories
with a little bit more vigor and hard
from the very beginning and I don't try
to meander as much as I had initially
done were you warming up in that 26
think it was I was still trying to learn
the crap
of screenwriting so at the time I was
just writing from a place this is what
everybody wants to say this is how they
want to say it and this is the key way
in order for them to be able to say it
but I didn't understand the craft and
the technique ports open in the film and
that your first opening image has to be
a story itself that's why my first film
was so riddled with dialogue and not
little that emotion and images because I
was all about what I had to say as
opposed to what I had to show we're
fast-forward now like I'm working on
another feature film which I cannot
believe I'm doing but 10 years later I'm
doing another feature film and
everything is image based so my first
scene I'm drawing what the image is and
then I'm deriving what has to be said
with embed for the story to truly live
like what information does the character
does the audience have to have in this
moment that's a complete different
approach from what I did in the very
beginning I was very much writing plays
on film and trying to film a play as
opposed to making a movie that 45000
forgive me if this is too personal but
that was meant for you to put a down
payment on a house right okay 25 was for
me to make a feature film so we got a
couple of investors to give one gave 25
another gave 10 in another game and
being the last 10 was kind of like
piecemeal together but that money was
literally sitting there for us to
actually make a film we had initially
budgeted 150,000 but we never got there
and I just decided to go ahead and make
the film which you shouldn't do you
should only make a project when you have
the financial resources to truly support
it other than that you'll just be
frustrated it as I was for that entire
year so if you could have changed things
you would have waited I would have
waited I would have waited I would have
gotten for some more perspective on the
screenplay I would have sent it off to
get coverage for people to tell me what
was wrong with it was right
I didn't know that was the thing you
could do at the time I made a lot of
mistakes I kind of feel like I didn't
cast the right people that I wanted to
necessarily cast even though I cast
where I was supposed to cast so I would
have made a lot of decisions differently
but I'm glad that I had that experience
because had I not I wouldn't know how to
be as savvy as I am with the budgets
that I do have now do you think it was
because you just wanted to make a movie
so badly
yep I want to do transform my career I
was in a place where I hadn't really had
I hadn't had a place to stay I had a
consistent income for quite a quite a
long time and I knew that if I was able
to make a piece that really connected
that somehow Hollywood would come
calling and it just didn't it didn't
happen like that and so I really decided
I would never make another feature film
ever again after that experience and
even the experience of going through
what I went through in sports
distribution was concerned and you know
getting picked up in Red Box nationwide
and getting a couple of dollars for it
even though the product the district
distributor made thousands you know so
to have those experiences to go to all
those things really put me in a place
where I'm like I want to make films but
I don't want to be a part of this
business right this juggernaut that has
Hollywood but here I am still
participate
you